THE COMMITTEE
WILL COME TO ORDER. GOOD
AFTERNOON EVERYONE IN RESPONSE
TO THE COVERT NINETEEN
EMERGENCY AND TO PROTECT THE
PUBLIC LEGISLATORS AND
EMPLOYEES WE MUST LIMIT
NONESSENTIAL GATHERINGS AND IT
HERE TO SOCIAL DISTANCING AND
BASS COVERING GUIDELINES. IN
COMPLIANCE WITH THOSE ORDERS
THE SENATE HAS MADE NECESSARY
ADJUSTMENTS TO NORMAL PRACTICES
IN ORDER TO ENSURE THAT THE
PUBLIC CONTINUES TO HAVE ACCESS
TO THE LEGISLATIVE PROCESS. WE
ARE HOLDING OUR COMMITTEE
HEARINGS HERE IN THE CAPITAL
WITH SOME MEMBERS ABLE TO
PARTICIPATE REMOTELY TODAY THE
MEMBERS OF THE SUBCOMMITTEE ARE
HERE IN THE HEARING ROOM. TO
ALLOW THE PUBLIC AXIS WE HAVE
ADMITTED MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
TO THE HEARING ROOM TO THE
EXTENT THAT SOCIAL DISTANCING
REQUIREMENTS ALLOW. AND WE WILL
BE USING A TELECONFERENCE
SERVICE FOR THOSE INDIVIDUALS
WHO WISH TO TESTIFY TODAY. FOR
ALL INDIVIDUALS WISHING TO
PROVIDE PUBLIC COMMENT. THE
PARTICIPANT TOLL FREE NUMBER
AND ACCESS CODE IS POSTED ON
OUR COMMITTEE WEBSITE AND I
WILL ANNOUNCE IT NOW. TODAY'S
PARTICIPANT NUMBER. IS.
877-226-8152 AND THE ACCESS
CODE IS. EIGHT ONE EIGHT TWO
EIGHT ONE SEVEN. FOR DETAILED
INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW THE TOP
TELECONFERENCES TO MARKS PLEASE
REFER TO THE SENATE OR THE
COMMITTEE WEBSITE. PLEASE NOTE
THAT IN ORDER FOR US TO HEAR
YOU CLEARLY AND TO AVOID
ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK YOU MUST MUTE
THE DEVICE YOU ARE WATCHING THE
HEARING ON PRIOR TO GIVING
TESTIMONY OVER THE PHONE IT IS
IMPORTANT THAT WE HEAR FROM YOU
AND WE THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PATIENCE. I WILL OF COURSE
REMAIN MAINTAIN DECORUM DURING
THE HEARING AS IS CUSTOMARY AND
ANY INDIVIDUALS WHO MADE. WHO
ARE DISRUPTIVE MAY BE REMOVED
FROM THE REMOTE MEETING SERVICE
OR HAVE THEIR CONNECTIONS
MUTED- I HAVE NEVER HAD TO DO
THIS SO I DON'T EXPECT WILL
WILL HAVE THIS PROBLEM TODAY.
WHILE EVERY EFFORT HAS BEEN
MADE TO STREAMLINE THE HIRING
PROCESS AND CONDUCT OUR
HEARINGS IN IS CLOSE TO THE
SAME MANNER AS IS CUSTOMARY.
THERE MAY BE SOME LAG TIMES FOR
PARTICIPANTS WHO ARE ADJUSTING
TO THE NEW USE OF ONLINE TOOLS
OR TECHNOLOGIES. PLEASE BE
RESPECTFUL AND PATIENT SAID SO
THAT ALL INTERESTED PARTIES CAN
BE HEARD. THIS IS OUR FINAL
SUBCOMMITTEE NUMBER FOUR
HEARING AND TODAY'S HEARING
WILL BE A VOTE ON THE CALENDAR
FOR STATE ADMINISTRATION ITEMS.
ALTHOUGH TO BE TAKEN ONCE WE
HAVE COMPLETED PUBLIC COMMENT
WE'VE BEEN OVER THESE
PARTICULAR ITEMS IN THE PAST SO
THESE ARE NOT NEW BUT THEY'RE
HERE BEFORE US FOR A VOTE ONLY.
SO BEFORE WE BEGIN WE'RE GOING
TO ESTABLISH A QUORUM WHAT THE
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
CARREIRO PRESENT THEIR PRESENT
POMEGRANATES. NIELSEN. NIELSEN
PRESS. A QUORUM HAS BEEN IT HAS
BEEN A STAB. SO GONNA START
WITH AN WANTING PROVIDE PUBLIC
COM REGARDING I IT ARE ON THE
VOTE ON PART OF THE AGENDA AS A
REMINDER TODAY'S PARTICIPANT
NUMBER IS. 877-226-8152 AND THE
ACCESS CODEIS. EIGHT ONE EIGHT
TWO EIGHT ONE SEVEN. DUE TO
CONSTRAINTS REGARDING THE
LENGTH OF HEARINGS TESTIMONY
CONSIDER TECHNOLOGY
CONSIDERATIONS AND CLEANING
PROTOCOLS THE CHAIR MAY LIMIT
TIME. I'M AT THE TIME ON
TESTIMONY TODAY I'M GOING TO
ASK THAT EACH MEMBER OF THE
PUBLIC PROVIDING COMMENTS KEEP
THE REMARKS TWO WITHIN A MINUTE
NOW LET'S BEGIN WITH ANY
WITNESSES HERE IN THE HEARING
ROOM. THERE ARE NONE. OKAY SO
WE'RE GONNA MOVE ON TO THE
WITNESSES WAITING TO PROVIDE
PUBLIC COMMENT VIA THAT THE
TELECONFERENCE I'M WE USUALLY
GO TO ANOTHER ROOM. LET ME SEE
IF THERE'S ANYONE IN THE OTHER
HEARING ROOM. THERE IS NO ONE
SO NOW WE'RE GOING TO MOVE ON
TO THE WITNESSES WAITING TO
PROVIDE PUBLIC COMMENT VIA THE
TELECONFERENCE THIS MODERATOR
IF YOU WOULD PLEASE PROMPT THE
INDIVIDUALS WAITING TO PROVIDE
PUBLIC COMMENT WE ARE READY TO
BEGIN. AND LATE IN GERMAN IF
YOU WOULD LIKE TO PROVIDE
PUBLIC COMMENT VIA
TELECONFERENCE PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO AT THIS TIME. YOU HEAR A
TONE INDICATING PLACING QUEUE.
BY THE NUMBER THAT I WILL
ANNOUNCE YOU BY THAT NUMBER
ONCE AGAIN TO PROVIDE PUBLIC
COMMENTS PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO
AT THIS TIME. ENSURE THIS TIME
IF WE DO HAVE ABOUT FOUR IN THE
QUEUE VERY GOOD MISTER MODERATE
IF YOU COULD- PLEASE OPEN A
LINE. WE WILL START WITH NUMBER
TEN. TO NUMBER TEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR HOW
WE ARE MEMBERS MICHAEL DEATH
WITH A GRAY AND MAKE ON OF THE
WORKFORCE US TO AND FORTY FIVE
FOR THEREAFTER A CROSS CAL.
CALIFORNIA WORKFORCE. AT YOU'VE
ALMOST HIRING. THAT CAN HELP UP
TO THREE TO NINE HOW TO BE EACH
YEAR AND ALSO CREATE AN DRIVER.
AS THEY MOVE TO RE. AND ENJOY
ADVANTAGE OF YOU TAX OF LIKE
THIS. ALSO WOULD LIKE TO
ADDRESS THE DEEP DOLLAR ONE
TIME CHEN FUND THE WORKS FOR
BOARD TO FIND REGIONAL IN
RECOVERY. AS DESCRIBE IN THE
GOT MARY. BILLING STATED THAT
IT PROVIDE A COMBAT GRANTS
REGIONALLY ORGANIZED WORKFORCE
BOARDS TO REACH PARTNERS. BUT
THIS LANGUAGE IS AND- RECORD
SPENDING THE GOVERNOR BY THE
JOY EDT CAL WORKFORCE BOARD
DIRECTOR. FROM JANUARY. TWENTY
NINE TWENTY ONE. REGIONAL LOCAL
PLANNING GUY FOR PAYMENT YOU.
TWENTY TWENTY ONE TO TWENTY
TWENTY FOUR. WE SIMILAR TO COME
WITH MORE ON THE MATTER THANK
YOU FOR YOUR CONSIDER OF THIS.
YOU ARE AMONG ISSUE FIFTY THREE
COUNTY VETERANS SERVICES
OFFICERS ADDITIONAL FUNDING WE
LIKE PROPER THAT THE COURT. OF
THE VENTURA COUNTY AND
RIVERSIDE COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS- ISSUE FIFTY FOR
THE PROPERTY TAX BACKFILL FOR
TWENTY TWENTY WILDFIRES-
HEARING SUPPORT OF THAT IN A
CREEK COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS. ON ISSUE FIFTY
FIVE THE APARTMENT APPEALED FOR
DEADLINE EXTENSION. HERE INTO
COURT ON BEHALF OF THE URBAN
CHINESE THE CALIFORNIA. AND
FINALLY AND ITEM FIFTEEN THANK
THAT CHANGES TO BETTER CONTROL
SECTION ELEVEN. NINETEEN I ALSO
WENT TO COURT ON BEHALF OF THE
IRVINE COUNTY THAT CALIFORNIA.
APPRECIATE YOUR TIME TODAY.
THANK THANK YOU VERY MUCH. NEXT
PLEASE. NEXT TO NUMBER TWENTY
THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD. MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE IN
PHILLY'S SHAW ON BEHALF OF THE
PORT OF SAN FRANCISCO ON ISSUE
NUMBER TWO WE STRONGLY SUPPORT
THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED TWO
HUNDRED AND FIFTY MILLION FROM
FEDERAL AND TECHNICALLY FANS
FOR OUTPATIENT STATE WIDE
CALIFORNIA REPORT. OVER THE
COURSE OF THE PAST YEAR TOURISM
TRAVEL AND HOSPITALITY SERVICES
SUCH AS CRUDE AS HOTELS
RESTAURANTS ATTRACTIONS AND
CONVENTION STALLED AND THEN
GROUND TO A HALT AND REPORT THE
RESULTS OF CALIFORNIA OR ITS
LIKE SAN FRANCISCO'S HAVE FACED
OVER 50% DECLINE IN REVENUE
COMPARED TO LAST YEAR. THESE
ACTIVITIES AND INDUSTRIES ARE
THE MAIN SOURCES OF SUPPORT FOR
THESE INDEPENDENT PUBLIC
AGENCIES WE ARE YOUR SUPPORT
CURRENT THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL
I DON'T FEEL LIKE TO TESTIFY ON
BEHALF OF THE CITY OF LOS
ANGELES MAYOR ERIC GARCETTI IN
SUPPORT. OF ISSUE NUMBER
TWENTY. THE DEPARTMENT OF
CANNABIS CONTROL TO BILL
LANGUAGE- WE ARE VERY IN. OF
THE LANGUAGE THAT WOULD HAVE.
CONSOLIDATE THE DUTIES OF THE
STATE AGENCIES EXTEND
PROVISIONAL LICENSES AND PER
THE LOCAL JURISDICTION GRANT
PROGRAMS WE ARE ALSO SUPPORTIVE
OF THE SENATE PROPOSAL TO
INCLUDE FUNDING FOR EQUITY
PROGRAM THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT PLEASE.
NEXT WILL BE NUMBER ELEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
CHAIR AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY
NAME IS JASON CAMERON I AM THE
DIRECTOR OF MILITARY AND
VETERANS AFFAIRS FOR BOTH THE
MONTEREY AND SAN BENITO
COUNTIES AS THE VETERAN SERVICE
OFFICER FOR THESE COUNTIES AND
A MEMBER OF THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF COUNTY VETERAN
SERVICE OFFICERS. I'D LIKE TO
PERSONALLY THANK YOU FOR
LOOKING TO INCREASE THE CBSL
FUNDING IN ISSUE FIFTY THREE
HOWEVER WE'RE CONCERNED THAT
THERE'S A POSSIBILITY THAT THIS
MAY BE GRANTED AS ONE TIME AND
NOT ON GOING THIS WOULD MAKE IT
TREMENDOUSLY DIFFICULT FOR
COUNTIES THROUGHOUT THE STATE
TO MAKE NEW HIRES DUE TO NON
CONTINUED FINDING. ATTRACT
QUALITY EMPLOYEES THAT WOULD-
BE HIGHER POTENTIALLY AS
TEMPORARY DUE TO PROJECTED
FUNDING CONSTRAINTS HI EFFORTS
TO TRAIN VETERANS SERVICE REPS
CAN TAKE ANYWHERE BETWEEN SIX
MONTHS TO A YEAR- THESE ARE THE
FOLKS WHO WOULD BE GOING DOWN
TO- AND PROVIDING THE SERVICES
TO THE MUCH NEEDED- I'M VALUE-
UNINCORPORATED AREAS OF THE
COUNTIES THROUGHOUT THE-
THROUGHOUT THE STATE. THE
INCREASE IN A NUMBER OF
VETERANS AND FAMILY MEMBERS
ACCESSING THESE EARNED
BENEFITS- TAKES A PROACTIVE
MEASURE AND BY HAVING FULL TIME
PERMANENT STAFF ADDED TO OUR
COUNTY OFFICES WE CAN SHIFT
FROM A REACTIVE APPROACH TO A
PROACTIVE ONE I AM FOR THIS-
SENATE BUDGET SUB COMMITTEE TO
MAKE THIS FUNDING REQUEST HOLD
PERMANENT AND ONGOING. FOR OUR
VETERANS THEIR FAMILIES THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA AND
TOGETHER WITH THIS PERMANENT
FUNDING WE CAN CREATE A
PROACTIVE AN EQUITABLE APPROACH
TO SERVING OUR DISABLED HOUSE
BOUND MINORITY AND LGBTQ
VETERAN. POPULATION AS WELL AS
THEIR FAMILIES THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. NEXT. NEXT IS
NUMBER TWENTY ONE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON THANK YOU
MY NAME IS A GREENER SANTIAGO
AND I'M CALLING FROM GOLDEN
STATE OPPORTUNITY- JUST CALLING
TO SHARE THE GOAL OF THE
OPPORTUNITY. TO CONTACT THE
MILITARY IS OUT SHOULD TARGET
THOSE WHO ARE MOST IN NEED AND
ESPECIALLY THOSE WHO'VE BEEN
LEFT OUT OF FEDERAL BENEFITS
THIS IS AN OPPORTUNITY TO MAKE
SURE THE COMMUNITY COULD NOT
RECEIVE PAYMENT DON'T GET LEFT
OUT AND LEFT BEHIND. AND
ESPECIALLY PLEASE CONSIDER
AFFECTS FOR CALIFORNIANS WHO
ARE WITHOUT THE SOCIAL SECURITY
NUMBER OR AND I CAN'T WAIT. TO
THERE ARE SUPPORT AS WELL.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
NEXT. NEXT TO BE NUMBER TWENTY
FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS JONATHAN CLAY
ON BEHALF OF THE PORT OF SAN
DIEGO CALLING IN SUPPORT OF
ISSUE NUMBER TWO THE ECONOMIC
SUPPORT FOR THE PORCH- JUST
ECHOING THE COMMENTS OF MY-
PREVIOUS COLLEAGUES FROM THE
PORT OF SAN FRANCISCO WE JUST
URGE YOUR SUPPORT OF THIS
MEASURE THE FORCING IT HAS BEEN
SIGNIFICANTLY IMPACTED BY
CANNABIS- GIVEN OUR TWENTY
THREE PUBLIC PARKS. CONVENTION
CENTER HOTELS ECCENTRIC THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU. NEXT
PLEASE. NEXUS NUMBER TWENTY
FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. THIS IS
MARK STARS FOR THE CALIFORNIA
HOUSING PARTNERSHIP AND WE'RE
IN VERY STRONG SUPPORT OF ISSUE
NUMBER EIGHT WHICH IS AN
ADDITIONAL FIVE HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS IN LOW INCOME HOUSING
TAX CREDITS FOR THE NEXT
CALENDAR YEAR- THESE RESOURCES
ARE CRITICAL TO BEING ABLE TO
INCREASE OUR AFFORDABLE HOUSING
PRODUCTION IN CALIFORNIA AND AT
SOME POINT WE URGE THE
COMMITTEE TO AFTER THREE YEARS
OF IT THANK YOU YOU KNOW THE
ANNUAL APPROPRIATIONS TO MAKE
THIS A PERMANENT PORTION OF THE
STATE'S BUDGET. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT. NEXT
TO TWENTY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
AFTERNOON THIS IS ON A HOUSE
ABOUT WITH UNITED WAYS OF
CALIFORNIA SPEAKING ON ISSUE
THIRTY EIGHT GOLDEN STATE
STIMULUS TO- WE DO SUPPORT THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL AND THE
RECOMMENDATIONS OF THE- THE
STAFF TO THE COMMITTEE TODAY
HOWEVER WE DO WANT TO ECHO THE
COMMENTS OF MY COLLEAGUE AT
GOLDEN STATE OPPORTUNITY- TO
EMPHASIZE THE NEED TO PAY
ATTENTION TO THE MILLIONS OF
EXCLUDED WORKERS AND FAMILIES
IN CALIFORNIA THAT HAVE NOT
BEEN ABLE TO ACCESS. HE KELLY
H. U. G. THE GOLDEN GATE
JUNIORS OR FEDERAL RELIEF WE
THINK WE CAN DO A LOT MORE HERE
IN CALIFORNIA FOR THOSE
INDIVIDUALS AND FAMILIES AND
HARDEST HIT AND ON THE FRONT
LINES OF THE PANDEMIC WE
ENCOURAGE THE COMEDIAN BUDGET
LEADERS- TO THOUGHTFULLY
CONSIDER OPPORTUNITIES TO PUT
FORWARD- RELIEF- THE SYSTEMS
FOR THESE INDIVIDUALS. IN
BUDGET ACTIONS IN THE FUTURE.
AND WE THANK YOU FOR ALL YOUR
WORK ON THIS. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH NEXT. NEXT TO NUMBER
TWENTY PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK
YOU THE FACILITY A FIVE MINUTE
LEADERSHIP COUNSEL FOR JUSTICE
AND ACCOUNTABILITY HERE TO
COMMENT ON ISSUE NINE THE DRAFT
TRANSITION ROAD MAP- AND WITH
THE ALLOCATION OF FOUR HUNDRED
AND SIX THOUSAND DOLLARS FOR
STAFFING AND WE WANT TO
ADVOCATE FOR THE OPR TO MAKE
SURE THAT DEVELOPING AND
IMPLEMENTING THE JUST
TRANSITION ROADMAP. THAT
INCLUDED ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT
PLANNING AND IMPLEMENTATION
CHALLENGES THE MISINFORMED
CLASSES AND RACES BELIEF THAT
LOWER INCOME COMMUNITIES OF
COLOR CAN'T HAVE HIGH QUALITY
JOBS CAREER OPPORTUNITY TO
CLEAN WATER AND CLEAN AIR.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
NEXT. NEXT TO BE NUMBER TWENTY
EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD. MADAM
CHAIR MEMBERS CHRIS RESPONSES
POLICY ADVOCATE WESTERN CENTER
ON LAW AND POVERTY ECHOING THE
COMMON ABOUT MY COLLEAGUES
PREVIOUSLY- TO ENSURE THAT
DOCUMENT CALIFORNIA TO LIKE
ANSEL SECURITY NUMBER AND I
TEN. ACCESSIBLE THE STATE'S
THEM ANYWHERE I IN ADDITION WE
ALSO ENCOURAGE LEGISLATURE TO
INCLUDE GENERAL SYSTEM
RECIPIENTS WHO ARE MOST NEED OF
ADDITIONAL PANDEMIC RELIEF
RIGHT NOW TO BE INCLUDED IN THE
GOLDEN STATE. ANNOUNCED THAT
CAN ATTRACT. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. NEXT PLEASE. NEXT TO
NUMBER THIRTY PLEASE GO AHEAD.
TRADEMARK OF MILLER WITH THAT
CALIFORNIA'S DIVISION OF CORDED
THIRTIES- CALLING IN STRONG OR
AN ISSUE TO WHICH IS THE
ECONOMIC SUPPORT FOR CALIFORNIA
COURT ACTUAR THIRTY MILLION
DOLLAR ONE TIME I THE GOAL
RECOVERY FINALLY TO ALLOCATE TO
THE PARKS AND THAT PROVIDE A
VITAL ROLE IN OUR STATE'S
ECONOMY EMERGING POTENTIAL
EARLY ON IN THAT IN THE
PANDEMIC I'VE HAD CONTINUE TO
OPERATE. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. NEXT PLEASE. NEXT IS
NUMBER TWENTY SIX PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR AND
MEMBERS- THE MONTEREY COUNTY
HERE WITH JOHN BURTON ADVOCATES
FOR YOU. AND I'M CALLING TO
EXPRESS SUPPORT FOR COMPONENT
OF THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL TO
ADDRESS SOME OF THAT- ISSUE
THIRTY TWO AND THIRTY THREE
UNDER EACH TV ON THE AGENDA
TODAY THE INCLUSION OF EIGHTY
EIGHT MILLION DOLLAR
TRANSITIONAL HOUSING PROGRAM
PRIORITIZING FORMER PROCTER
PROBATION YOUTH. AND THE FIVE
MILLION DOLLAR HOUSING-NAVIGATOR PROGRAM PRIORITIZING
CURRENT DOCTOR YOU- ADDITION A
SHOCK YOU WOULD ALSO LIKE TO%
EXPRESS SUPPORT FOR THE
GOVERNOR'S MANSION OF A
TARGETED APPROACH TO THIRD YOU
HOME HE ADDED HERE AND LASTLY
WE JUST LIKE TO EXPRESS SUPPORT
FOR THE SENATE PLAN TO ADDRESS
HOMELESSNESS AND AFTER THAT THE
THANK YOU TRADEMARK IN THE
BRING CALIFORNIA HOMES. ACT TO
SHAKE THAT PROPOSAL AND IF
INCLUDE THE USE OF A HUNTER
THANK YOU THAT ASIDE- BECAUSE
HOME WITH YOU TO MAKE UP 10% OF
THE HOMELESS POPULATION IN
CALIFORNIA ON AVERAGE WHEN
LOOKING AT THE LAST THREE YEARS.
THANKS SO MUCH. THANK YOU. NEXT
PLEASE. WE DO HAVE ONE IN OF
THE JUST A MOMENT HERE. NEXT
WE'LL GO TO NUMBER THIRTY THREE
LINE THIRTY THREE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THAT THANK YOU JEFF NEAL
WITH THE CALIFORNIA STATE
ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES- WANTED
TO- APPRECIATE INTERJ THE
PASSAGE OF THE NUMBER OF ITEMS
HERE THAT THE PROPERTY TAX
BACKFILL IT HELPS WILD FIRE
AFFECTED THAT PUBLIC AGENCIES
THAT CONTINUE SERVING THE
PUBLIC HE SAID MANY KILLS BOARD
EXTENSION A CRITICAL FOR
PROPERTY TAXES. THE CBSL MONEY
CORPS VETERAN SERVICES AT AND
ALSO THE CONTROL SECTION ON THE
CORONAVIRUS RELIEF FUND. ALL.
OF THOSE AND URGE. MESSAGE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU FOR MUCH.
MISTER MODERATOR DO WE HAVE
ANYONE ELSE. WE DO HAVE ONE
MORE THAN JUST JOIN THE QUEUE
TO BE JUST A MOMENT. WE WILL BE
GOING TO WIND. THIRTY TWO. NINE
THIRTY TO PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR
MARKET GUERRERO REPRESENTING
THE LOS ANGELES COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS- AND- THIS IS
RELATED TO ISSUE NUMBER FIFTY
THREE A GREATLY APPRECIATE THE
APPROPRIATION- FOR ACTUALLY
FIFTY THREE WITH BERNIE COUNTY
VETERAN SERVICES OFFICER THE
ADDITIONAL FIVE POINT FOUR
MILLION A MERE REQUESTING THAT
THE APPROPRIATION BE ONGOING-
AND- WOULD LIKE TO CONTINUE TO
WORK WITH YOU ON THAT. THANK
YOU SO MUCH THANK YOU. MISTER
MODERATOR DO WE HAVE ANYONE
LAST ARE LEFT IN LINE. IN THE
QUEUE AT THIS TIME THERE ARE NO
OTHERS IN OUR QUEUE- PLEASE
CONTINUE. VERY GOOD THANK YOU
SO MUCH TO EVERYBODY WHO
TESTIFIED HERE TODAY HAVING
HEARD FROM ALL OF THE MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC- ANY OF THE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS HAVE ANY
COMMENTS OR- CONCERNS THAT THEY
LIKE TO RACE. SEEING NONE WERE
READY TO MOVE ON TO VOTE ON THE
CALENDAR. I'D LIKE TO START OFF
BY TAKING UP THE ISSUES IN
ITEMS NUMBER. ONE THREE FOUR
SIX SEVEN. EIGHT EVAN.
271-619-2220.
THREE TWENTY FOUR
TWENTY FIVE TWENTY NINE THIRTY
ONE THIRTY TWO THIRTY THREE
THIRTY FOUR THIRTY FIVE THIRTY
SIX THIRTY SEVEN FORTY ONE
FORTY TWO FORTY THREE FORTY
FOUR FORTY FIVE FORTY EIGHT
FORTY NINE. 1-015-253-5450 FIVE
AND FIFTY SIX DO WE HAVE A
MOTION ON THESE ISSUES. THE
MOTION IS MOVED BY SENATOR
KAMLAGER AND IT IT IS TO ADOPT
THE STAFF RECOMMENDATIONS MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
BARBERA I HAVE AEROHIVE'S TIME
LONGER KAMLAGER I'D NIELSEN.
AYE NIELSEN AYE. THOSE ITEMS A
PAST THREE EYES. ZERO KNOWS
NEXT WE'RE GOING TO BE TAKING
ITEM UP ISSUES NUMBER. FIVE
NINE FOURTEEN SEVENTEEN
EIGHTEEN. 262-728-3040 SIX AND
FORTY SEVEN DO WE HAVE A MOTION
ON THESE ITEMS. THERE IS A
MOTION THAT WE ADOPT THIS THE
STAFF RECOMMENDATIONS PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL CABALLERO I OF
AERO I'D COME LONGER. FROM
LONGER AYE NIELSEN NIELSEN NOW
THOSE ITEMS PASS TO I WON NO.
I'M MORE READY TO MOVE ON TO
THE REMAINING ITEMS WHICH ARE I
ISSUES NUMBER. TWENTY TWENTY
ONE. THIRTY EIGHT THIRTY NINE
AND FORTY IS THERE A MOTION ON
THESE ISSUES. MOVED BY SENATOR
TOM WALKER. TO ADOPT THE STAFF
RECOMMENDATION MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL CABALLERO
HI THERE HI TOM LONGER. COMMA I
NIELSEN NAY NIELSEN I'M STAYING
THE MOTION CARRIES TWO EYES.
ZERO KNOWS- THAT SO THAT
CONCLUDES- ARE ITEMS TO FOR
TODAY ONE OF THINKING EVERYONE
FOR YOUR PATIENCE AND
COOPERATION AND THANK THANK YOU
TO ALL THE INDIVIDUALS WHO
PARTICIPATED IN THE PUBLIC
TESTIMONY TODAY IF YOU WEREN'T
ABLE TO TESTIFY AND YOU WOULD
LIKE TO SUBMIT A COMMENT OR A
SUGGESTION YOU CAN WRITE YOU
SHOULD PUT IT IN WRITING TO THE
BUDGET AND FISCAL REVIEW
COMMITTEE OR VISIT OUR WEBSITE
YOUR COMMENTS AND SUGGESTIONS
ARE IMPORTANT TO US AND WE WANT
TO INCLUDE YOUR TESTIMONY IN
THE OFFICIAL HEARING RECORDS
THANK YOU AND AGAIN WE
APPRECIATE YOUR PARTICIPATION.
THE SENATE BUDGET IN FISCAL
REVIEW SUBCOMMITTEE FOR IS NOW
ADJOURNED.